stepping out and going full time on
youtube might seem
scary especially if you don't have the
right strategy and planning in place
you may be missing the full potential of
what's available on the platform
youtube is alive and healthy and it's
creating more
full-time content creators more
full-time youtubers
than ever before and if that seems like
something you want to do
you are in the right place my name is
heather torres and i want to welcome you
to the think marketing
podcast if you're new here i want to let
you know that we release an episode
every single tuesday
and consider subscribing by hitting
subscribe wherever
you're consuming this content we are in
part three of our how to quit your job
and become a full-time
youtuber and we've been diving into the
seven steps for achieving this these are
actually the seven steps
that sean cannell went through when he
went from flipping burgers
i mean serving burgers to becoming a
full-time content creator and then
growing into a multiple
seven-figure media company he started
solo probably
just like you and is now heading into
becoming the ceo
and doing all the wonderful things that
can happen when you go full-time
here on youtube now let's go ahead and
recap what we've covered so far and then
we'll dive
into the last steps of this seven step
system
we have started with start that was step
number one
step number two was skill up really
figuring out and mastering
your topic what do you want to teach and
how do you want to teach it and who are
you teaching too
really diving into knowing what skills
you need those hard and soft skills
for dominating here on youtube then
it was synergizing your schedule we
learned about the proximity principle
and what it means to actually put
yourself around the right people
and in the right positions to position
you
for success on the platform who do you
need to be around what books do you need
to consume what conferences should you
go to where should you be volunteering
or where should you be working for free
or
where do you actually need to relocate
your personal self like your family
all of these pieces of the proximity
principle are key to getting you
where you want to go then we learned
about some smart
systems and i included in the last
episode
some of the systems that we use here at
think media
in the description so if you want to
check that out that's at our
thinkmediatools.com
and that's a lot of the different
software that we use to be able to be
creating content
regularly on the platform if you're in
different seasons of life
it really is going to depend on how much
time you can commit to this and so
we really recommend batch producing
that's what i'm doing right now for the
podcast i just
change my shirt and we're recording five
episodes today so that we can get ahead
i'm a busy mom of three running this
company and i need to make sure that
smart systems
and smart software is what we're using
to be able to get the right content to
you
as quickly as possible now we're gonna
head into
the last steps of this system we're
gonna learn about
finding your sweet spot really what type
of content
are you creating and how are you able to
differentiate yourself
in the market that you're in how do you
find your niche or how do you go deeper
into knowing
your actual expertise in the market that
you want to serve
then you're going to learn about
creating that side income you know sean
really went full time by
moving his side income into his
full-time income
and then we're going to help you learn
when it's right to step
out becoming a full-time content creator
is not
easy and we want to make sure that you
understand the numbers you know
when it's right for you to actually dial
in and become
that full-time creator when do you put
in the two-week notice at your job or
when do you decide that you are doing
this full time
we're gonna help you with that and more
in today's training
step five step five on this journey
your goal is to eventually hone in on
your sweet spot
and what i mean is narrow your niche and
serve a specific audience
find your sweet spot narrow down your
niche and serve a specific
audience so when i started think media
at first
i was like i had actually like seemingly
a lot of clarity back in 2010
how to build a video editing [ __ ] pc
how to get started in video production
then i wandered off into some world of
of like
interviews with social media experts it
was it was cool but it got weird for a
while just different kind of things
and then it was like kind of dark for a
while i'm working on other projects
um but eventually i found my seat
sweet spot i want you to remember i'm
compressing almost a decade into like an
hour right as we hang out
and so eventually though it was like
okay
and when i started think media i just
said think media helping you go further
faster in media
that was my tagline and while that
actually was pretty decent at least it
was like sort of made sense
it was also very vague like what exactly
is media
and yeah i want to go further faster but
like so eventually today
it's now helping you with the best tips
and tools the strategies and the cameras
and the lighting
for building your influence online and
so we talk about gear and we talk about
strategies
but even in that process there are
nuances to our brand and the things that
have worked for us that i discovered and
here's what it is
it really this is one of them six years
ago this was a big aha moment put out a
video called best camera for youtube
to this day it got about a quarter
million views six years old so now we're
talking like 2013.
but here's my clarity camera reviews for
everyday people
like when i found like my thing like
that was it
camera reviews for everyday people
and here's what i mean here's a big
unlock that i experienced
a big lesson is that your audience is
infinitely more important
than your competitors and what i mean
is care more about here's a way to put
it in business care more about your
customers than your competition
okay and so at first what i learned
early on on youtube was i had a lot of
fear of judgment a lot of fear of what
other people would think
and i had like this desire to i
felt like the people who were creating
content the people that review were
reviewing cameras or talking about gear
and there wasn't many actually
but the people who were doing it i
thought at first
i was trying to impress them and i also
thought when i would watch their stuff i
was really worried if i said the right
thing
did i call the sens if i reviewed a
laptop did i
did i say the ram speed was fast enough
did it was it
hdmi input or was it an output and i
would get sometimes comments from tech
experts that were like you said the ram
was ddr2
but it's actually ddr3 and i'd be like
okay
bro you're right and i'm not even
faulting you for pointing it out
although you are kind of a jerk
but what i'm noticing is like you're
obsessed with all this kind of stuff but
here's what i've learned i'm
figuring out that my audience
think media this community and the
people were watching back then
i'm not trying to reach other tech
experts guess what if they're an expert
they're probably not going to listen to
this guy all i know
is i'm a small town college dropout you
know that
has some experience in video and that
knows this youtube space and knows
creators
so it was camera reviews for everyday
people and here was the switch
instead of saying like how to get depth
of field in your videos it was like how
to get a blurry background why
because everyday people say blurry
background and they don't know what
depth of field is
when i started to do camera reviews that
were empathetic
for the audience for like people who
didn't want to be tech experts
but just wanted to know will the camera
work will i be in focus
does it have a flip screen can i easily
tap the flip screen can i plug a mic in
easily will it sound good what are the
settings
so just keeping it really basic and when
i got out of my head and stopped
worrying about
my competition and started focusing on
serving
a specific person like a specific
audience
that's when everything blew up and
here's what's crazy or it's when things
really started to grow is i found my
sweet spot if you search best camera for
youtube think media this is like how
sweet of a spot this has been i mean
this is how many
camera best cheap cameras cameras versus
dslr
i mean you could see you find your sweet
spot
and then like work the thing that's
working every once in a while some hater
on think media will be like
you've kind of made a video like this
before i'd be like have you ever watched
the largest youtuber independent
youtuber his name's felix
dude he makes some similar videos and so
again worrying more about your your uh
your audience in your community than
your critics
but if something works work it and when
you find
your sweet spot i kept compounding
those videos year after year so that was
just a major key to going
full time because i dialed in to
my sweet spot i also began to learn at
first i was about tech everything
i was about tech you know a few uh
headphones which they still find their
way on here but like a few headphones
would find their way on there
some random i'm trying to forget like
like anything at ces would find its way
in on my channel
but i began to narrow and i realized
there's so much tech 3d printers all
these smartphones all this stuff
you know mkbhd all these other channels
i began to say okay no no this is just
tools for creators
the best tools for creators i'm going to
talk about cameras like i'm not talking
about 3d printers
i'm not talking about there's so many
tech
led lights like for your home smart home
home theater this is not what you find
here on think media it
was randomly like that in like 2013
but i began to narrow my niche into
tools for
creators that was a huge unlock and then
i began to serve a specific audience i
said creators
and those creators that are like doing
gardening channels and makeup channels
and homeschool channels and like
bible studies and all these different
things and they're not trying to become
camera experts man
so i wanted to start serving you and let
the experts if they
if i say the censor you know size
wrong or like not the quite right i know
you don't care
about the exact technical terminology
because what you've learned i get
messages all the time
bro thank you for mentioning the m50 i'm
in love with it
and to this day the canon m50 is still
one of the best cameras you know what
i'm saying like
it's serving real people be obsessed
with serving a specific audience
and then just block out all the other
noise and clutter because guess what
they're actually not even really
listening or paying attention oftentimes
anyways
but your goal is to become known for one
thing and here's what i learned
i started to become known as like oh
sean like dude that's the guy that like
helped me pick out my camera and my
lighting
oh he's like the camera guy or like oh
that's like the youtube guy
or that's like the guy that like he's
the guy that like will help me
you know set my youtube channel up what
are people saying about you
you want to go full time on youtube you
need to become the the
the yoga tips girl you're like well i i
do a lot more than yoga yeah but if you
want to become known you got to become
known for one thing if you really want
to blow up and grow you got to become
you know niche down if you try and reach
everybody you end up reaching nobody
and the world is so noisy it's harder
and harder than ever before
to do variety content am i saying it's
impossible no
am i saying you personally should not do
variety content no
to each his own i'm just saying what
i've learned and i've seen this prove
true across industries even social
channels
networks businesses you got to become
known for one thing if you really really
want to broke
break out so what is the one thing
you're going to become known for oh
that's the person that helps me with
taxes or
that's the person who is super funny
like they make great
comedy videos and one drops a week and i
always laugh that's the person
who is like that weird family that lives
off the grid and is like homesteading
and
it's so cool to watch like you got to
become known for one thing like
really brand yourself really position
yourself in a niche so when i started to
become like oh that's the guy that's
gonna help me with gear
it changed everything look it's okay to
actually not go full time it's okay to
do youtube as a hobby
it's okay to do youtube and just find
out a way to make
an extra five thousand dollars a year an
extra ten thousand dollars a year
you know maybe you can't live off that
but how cool would it be to just have
like kind of a side hustle
hobby that you could do that it's a big
reality
maybe you have an existing business and
you want to use youtube to support your
existing big
business let me know your ultimate goal
for being on youtube which brings us to
step
six side income
streams side income streams
and by this point you might be like yo
sean show me the money
jerry maguire if you don't know the
reference then um
that won't make sense but uh that was a
classic movie tom cruise
show me the money okay i'll show you the
money how
did i actually go full time well i did
it with youtube
and affiliate marketing and here's how
it worked
my first payment from affiliate
marketing was two dollars and 12 cents
in 2010.
amazing that's how you retire right
there right
like no of course not but this is
actually
really my favorite payment of all time
obviously i like it to be a lot bigger
than that but the reason it is is
because that was proof of concept
when i made my first two dollars online
and 12 cents
i was so pumped i was like dude no one
in my freaking neighborhood made two
dollars online
this month and maybe they did but
probably not
like my neighbors aren't hustling on
youtube they're not doing affiliate
market they're not figuring out this
stuff i was like dude i made two dollars
and 12 cents what if i could double it
and then what if i could double it again
right and so i want to encourage you
don't despise small beginnings when you
make that first dollar online and let me
know in the chat
or in the comments have you made your
first dollar online when you make that
first dollar it's proof of concept
because if you can make one you can make
more
and so my first payment from affiliate
marketing was 212
and this is why it's important to dream
big but start small
and act now because a lot of and i want
to encourage you if i can this is kind
of more of like a coaching kind of
i want i really want to encourage you
there is the season
that most won't make it through and it's
that sacrifice season
it's the 2.12 season and the reason
why is because people give up before the
breakthrough when you look at the
timeline i'm describing to you
this like your dreams your your
aspirations full-time on youtube
opportunity i heard it said once this
way opportunity
is missed by most people because it's
dressed in overalls
and it looks like work yeah you gotta
have big dreams
but when you get a two dollar check you
go that's not that big so you gotta
start small
but you got to act now and you got to
keep acting keep posting keep hustling
and keep focused and say look i'm not
worried about this two dollars
it's all bonus because i'm not focusing
on making money on youtube remember that
because i've got my bills paid because
i'm gonna go hustle and wait tables and
i can wake
i can make way more than two dollars and
twelve cents by going
to work at red robin and picking up a
shift
but what i did was i worked the minimum
amount i could at red robin to pay my
bills hustle make tips and double shift
so then i could go home and make two
dollars for like a hundred hours of work
right you know what i'm saying because
some of you you've put in the work and
you haven't made any money yet
you gotta press through that season
because as you climb out you get on the
other side that's where all
the accolades are right that's where the
magic happens by january 2013
now i'm making 259.90
that was a good month on amazon
affiliates
now i have a full-time job and i'm
freelancing so i'm making an extra 260
dollars in a month
let's go man like you know sony and i
are like hey like with my wife
like like let's this is amazing so it's
that's not like retiree money that's not
full-time money but that was the
progression for me
and again i was delayed because i was
spread all over the place
and uh i could have pro i could have
grown this a lot faster but i was just
i was so scattered by 2015 february
and one dollars and sixteen cents cool
right so
and that was uh december why affiliate
marketing holiday shopping like
it just usually goes up and so almost a
grand
you wanna talk about a happy christmas
like we're talking an
extra 901 dollars on top of having a
full-time job
now now my side hustle stuff i'm like
dang this is like legit this is really
happening and then i went full-time
starting november
2015. um and so
check it out uh by
here's february 1st 2016 but you get
paid about a three-month delay on amazon
affiliates
so now in the beginning of 2016
4704 3879
and that was uh when i say full time i
technically went full time
as kind of an entrepreneur at the
beginning of 2015 and i had three main
freelance clients
but then what happened in october is
they fired me and they all fired me one
a week for three weeks
and i say fired one
two really fired me and one it was kind
of just a transition they were hiring
some other staff
and whatever and the same thing with the
other people they were like you know we
don't need you anymore we're
transitioning and so it wasn't like
burnt bridges like everything's so good
with all those people but the point is
we lost 90 of our income in one month
and i was freaked out
but as i look back in hindsight that was
when i went all in and that's when this
happened
because right in like november 1st is
when i got started working and i just
started making videos
talking about tech right around the
holidays black friday cyber monday all
that kind of stuff
but then boom and we had a little bit of
savings so the first couple months
weren't that great you know what i mean
like a couple
low months 1564. this is not a great
like pay your rent and
you know everything else month but after
a few
months it kicked in and we started to
make a little bit more
now here's another thing is this is also
why i'm not that big a fan of youtube
ads
there's very few niches where it's super
relevant especially at first
between november 2015 and february 2016
an additional 839.43 from youtube ads
that's over uh uh november
december january and february it's like
a four month period so like an extra 200
bucks a month which is great
but it was like cool like let's just
we'll just let that happen i almost
ignore it i'm like
reinvest that money back into the
business back into the channel
back into my personal development all
that kind of stuff
affiliate marketing is the thing that
that is happening and so
that's what i want to encourage you you
want to find your
stream you want to find a stream
affiliate marketing is amazing i think
we should all do it
but it doesn't work as good in every
single niche but there's so many things
that do i mean whether it is
crowdfunding or patreon or brand deals
or youtube ads because you have a
channel that has high view
like kind of like a prank channel or
something like that um but whatever it
is
but uh yeah find your sweet spot a
couple tips
turn streams into rivers
so if we're gonna follow one course
until successful step one
start some youtube videos step two
eventually find a way to make money and
make your first two dollars
that's a stress not even a stream that
is a trickle that is like
a dried up riverbed and you're like oh
look there's drops of water going down
but man i hear the sound of rain you
know what i'm saying and so you see
those drops
then you want that to be a stream then
you want it to be a a a trickle
people that focus on multiple streams of
income too early
spread themselves too thin i found out
what was working and i was like okay i
know how to rank videos
i'm i know that i'm doing tech reviews
and i'm doing that kind of stuff
i know about affiliate marketing i know
about youtube i'm gonna get
this thing i'm not gonna try to do
anything else i'm gonna get this thing
so when i
lost my clients november december that
was all in
i worked 60 to 80 hour weeks videos
videos videos i would
because i realized if i can upload more
and maybe
two videos even do that good but one
crushed if i can get more outputs out
if i can upload more if i can do more
research whatever
turn streams into rivers you want to
find a little trickle and get it gushing
and what sometimes people do is they get
their
their trickle to a stream and then they
actually start starting another stream
and so if you're making 200 bucks a
month in affiliate marketing for example
you don't want to take your eye
necessarily off the prize on that thing
what you want to do is actually keep
focusing on that thing until that stream
becomes a river
instead of just having a bunch of baby
streams everywhere makes sense
so really staying focused um
tip two momentum and compound effort
will lead to bigger checks and bigger
opportunities you've seen it here
you've seen you saw it on my affiliate
account right just started a compound it
just started to grow
and now we that year 2016
hits i hit six figures in affiliate
marketing
i believe i got a screenshot for you
actually um and so
okay not probably not that year that
year's probably like 80k
but see by november that year 11 165 39
pretty cool right so then definitely by
i think by the next year is multiple six
and by that year
a couple other income streams yeah it
was six figures
so all of the proximity principle and
all the groundwork i laid and all of
those things
began to really come into fruition at
that jump off point
in 2015. and so
um
okay and so yeah streams side
income streams notice when this is
happening we talked about those
different seasons we talked about
uh those different steps but eventually
you want to get your streams
generating right you want to get your
streams happening and
i don't have time to go into how to rank
videos
how to make money on youtube affiliate
marketing and the exact strategies but
i just want to put this on your radar
some people in our community have seen
this and they've been raving about it
but we have i have a one hour master
class that's
way more about youtube this is kind
about how to go full time in life and
the whole thing
if you want some my best strategies and
specific
tactics for getting views ranking videos
and if you're not sure what sure that
means you'll want to see this
then i do have a free training it's our
master class that normally
exists inside of our um like private
communities like our video ranking
academy community
but we've taken out an hour of that
training and you can watch it entirely
for free
so if you're be interested in that then
um this is what it is it's three
strategies for growing your audience and
income on youtube in 2019
the new rules of youtube success my
proven system for getting views on
youtube 24 7.
three creative ways to earn an extra
thousand per month other ways
besides affiliate marketing and then
some case studies
from how three regular people used a
simple youtube strategy to quit their
job and create a full-time income
so i teach all of that make sure to
check this out it's at
thinkmasterclass.com and you can watch
it for free for a limited time
and so check that out for specifics
on ranking videos getting more views
getting subscribers
and let's move on to tip number
seven which is step
out so how do you know when to go full
time
how do you know when to step out well
for me
i've learned some things since then i
told you my story i
i might jump into full time i'll be
honest i was scared
and i'm sure you feel the same i mean
self-doubt can i make it even with
results that we had i mean think media
when i jumped out we had 16 000
subscribers
and we're a little over 800 000 now but
and 16 000 is solid but scary like
wait this is gonna be like your
full-time job like your mom like wait
you're gonna you're doing what like how
are you gonna support your family
sean like you're like look i got these
16 000 subscribers on youtube you know
trust me
you know what i'm saying it's kind of
scary i'm so thankful to god that
as an entrepreneur which is what you are
if you're a youtuber you just really are
like you're building something
on the side and your neighbors aren't
and that's not right or wrong
like you just want more you aspire to do
something you you don't want to just be
a consumer you want to be a creator
and so uh any entrepreneur creator that
steps out
there's a point when you have to jump
off the cliff i'm thankful that i got
kicked off you know what i mean
because i could have went back and kept
freelancing but that was the
tipping point no longer having freelance
clients and i didn't have a job so now
in in november 1st
2015 i'm like i got no boss all i got is
time on my hands now
i got no more freelance clients i'm all
freaking in
and i was just desperate and hungry and
and
and so i just went all in at some point
though
you need to make the jump but how do you
know when
to do it here's my advice define this
and really define this pull out a piece
of paper or your phone right now
whatever
and and write down how much do you need
to live on
most people have never done this most
people that want to go full time have
never done this how much do you need to
live on and not
like that jay-z beyonce lifestyle you're
like well the private jet
and the crystal no no you know what i'm
saying i'm talking about like
how much could you live on if this this
includes your dependence this includes
other things
but really to find that number that you
would need to live
every month i knew back even during that
time i was scared because yeah we had
freelance clients and
we're living in vegas cost of living is
pretty good but also as
independent entrepreneur freelancer all
of our
insurance was on us right health care uh
health bills
um everything business taxes just
everything because
we it was all on us so we had to come up
with that number of what do we need bare
minimum
to live and if you were willing to
bootstrap a little bit and i'm not
talking about like
we're not going to eat which was not
what you would do but of course
you know like you got to eat but like
really lean
like if you could be lean for 12 months
24 months to position yourself
to go full time and so define that
figure
is it 4 000 a month is it 2 500 a month
because you can is it 1500 a month
because you can sleep on a couch and
your friends giving you a free
like or or are you living in the heart
of manhattan
and you've got eight kids um in an
apartment
and you need 250 000 a year to live like
at the base level
i mean that's where you live it all
matters
but you really need to figure out that
target how much do you need to live
and the move might be to actually reduce
your overhead
remember like what what if you moved
what if you downsized your life
so that you could upsize your youtube
dream
you know what i mean so define how much
you need to live and then check this out
apply the 25 rule apply the 25
rule i'm going to go with 4 000 for easy
math because i'm not good at math
if you need four thousand dollars a
month to live
then i recommend the 25
rule and that is this as soon as you've
hit
25 of your
target minimum monthly income how much
would that be
one thousand dollars meaning you're
hustling on youtube
you got your side hustle however you're
monetizing when you
you know four thousand is a target and
you hit one thousand
it's your jump off point it's your jump
off point
because if you can make one thought
here's what you've proven
you've proven you can make 25 percent of
your monthly income which by the way
at this point is in addition to the
monthly income you're
you're making right because you have the
point of this video is
quitting your job so it's assuming you
have a job that's what we're assuming
right
and so if you don't have a job and you
can just hustle from home that's i know
all of our circumstances you're
different
but your job is paying you four thousand
your
side hustle has now earned you a
thousand here's what you've proven
you've proven that in your spare time by
punting leisure by being disciplined by
being focused
by obviously getting subscribers and
viewers and getting some things
you've proven that you can make a
thousand dollars a month by the way
25 of your target what happens
when you go all in from that point
you'll make it
makes sense because now you don't have
i just talked to somebody on a coaching
call and there's like a ability to do
private coaching with me
it's it's kind of expensive so but
that's on my website but
i was doing a private coaching call the
other day and i was talking to a person
who
um had a two-hour commute both ways to
work
and then a full work day and the person
actually had a background in
entrepreneurship and some other things
and
different ways to make money and i was
like bro you need to buy some time
i was like what happens when you don't
have that commute anymore and when you
don't have work of that job anymore
it's game over because i know you're a
hustler i know you know what to do
and if you're applying the 25 rule that
means you've already hit a financial
target
makes sense so you can go freaking all
in and now
that's what happened to me like when i
went all in
i was able i'm not saying forever but i
was able to work
insane hours to
build in the other 75 now of course the
disclaimer here
is please don't email me if this doesn't
work out for you
nothing is guaranteed you know what i'm
saying and so i'm not saying like this
is some universal law like sean said 25
is like this magic i'm not saying it's a
magic uh
you know number but it is a formula and
i think it probably is resonating with
you
because you could see that makes sense
like if i can prove that i am
good for generating 25 from my side
hustle
that man when i go all in in it then i
can get that thing to my full-time
income and man
it's freedom like as soon as my clients
let me go and i went all in
i was like dude this is christmas every
day that's how i feel to this day i feel
that way just
i live in an unreal gratitude because of
the hustle i've put in
to get where i am today and so that jump
off point when you're able to wake up
my commute now is you know about
well i have to go down to an espresso
machine first so it's like that but if
it's straight from
you know to get to this office is uh a
step over rosie my chihuahua
a step over sophie my chihuahua and then
i'm here you know what i'm saying and
i say that just because this is possible
especially
if you make a plan like it can be
practical define how much you need to
live on
and then apply the 25 role when you hit
that target
of course if you got other decision
makers in your family please get
you know talk to your spouse about this
whatever of course
but then made up make a plan and jump
off and at some point
what happens is that's still really
scary well what if the other money
doesn't come in
you know what i told myself when when we
went all in i was like look we're six
months away
from bankruptcy meaning all of our
savings would be gone
like when i lost my clients i was like
this is either gonna work or it's not
but what's the worst that could happen
i could get more clients i could go get
another job
or i could just go work at red robin
over here because i am
lethal at red robin you would be too if
you spent 10 years there
i still know the whole menu you know
what i mean like i
i am the master of bottomless fries and
so that's something they have there so
anyways
know when to go full time do those tips
remember
overnight success never happens over
night i know it seems that way as people
just pop up and blow up on youtube
over tonight's success never happens
overnight
but most people underestimate what they
can do or most people overestimate what
they can do in a year
but they underestimate what they can do
in five to ten and so when you
set your mind on this and you get
focused and you follow these tips you
can do this
all right well that is the end of the
seven steps now let's recap
what we learned in today's episode we
first started out with
finding your sweet spot who do you serve
and how do you serve them
and what makes you special in the market
that you're trying to reach
i think this is something that is over
time something that you're going to
keep refining and keep refining but i
want you to actually
have a north star really identifying who
you want to help and how you want to
help them
is critical when it comes to creating
content and if you are just starting
i want you to start with just the target
audience who do you want to help
maybe you can try different ways of
helping them to find the sweet spot
first just like shawn did
but over time you'll get clearer and
clearer on this mission
and i think about even myself and what
i've been experiencing on my own
side youtube channel in homeschooling i
started just making a bunch of different
types of content but i know who i was
serving i knew
who i wanted to serve and i knew i
wanted to help them with homeschooling
and then from there i started to refine
it more and more
and now i know that i really help newer
homeschoolers
understand the differences in
alternative education it doesn't mean
that i'm not doing things on curriculum
or doing
videos on schedules but i really want to
be more of an educator
someone who's just a friend along the
journey
just a little bit ahead so i want to ask
you have you found your sweet spot yet
or are you still in that refining
clarity process
then number two we learned about
creating that side income and sean
really shared his journey about
going through affiliate marketing and
what that's done for him from that first
check of
two dollars and 12 cents all the way
into now making
tens of thousands of dollars from amazon
affiliate alone
and if affiliate marketing is something
you would like to learn more about we
actually did a two-part series here
on the podcast that you can check out
and i'll link that in the show notes as
well as in the description
if that's something that you want to go
deeper on and for me
personally my side income was really
one-on-one coaching
i did a lot of one-on-one coaching where
i was able to really decide
who i wanted to help and how i wanted to
help them and that ultimately was what
led me into starting an agency
and then helping in other ways for small
businesses i really wanted to
be a mom that was present with my kids
and was able to make my own calendar and
work my own schedule around the things
that were important to our family and so
i knew that
creating a career by creating content
was something that i needed to do
and so it started slow i started with
one client and then two clients
but over time that was what helped me go
from
working a full-time job and then
becoming a full-time content creator
here on
think it's important that you know that
there's lots of different ways that you
can create a side income
but affiliate marketing is great because
you get to sell other people's products
the products and services that you love
and would recommend to your friends
that's a way that you can get started
and your first check may be
just like shawn's two dollars and 12
cents but it's actually just
evidence that this can work for you as
well so if you want to go deeper in that
series i'll make sure to link it up
and then lastly we learned about
stepping out and going full time
really doing the math for the mission
understanding what are the numbers
what's the sacrifice that you're going
to need to make in order to have
success later on i think it's important
to know that in order to go full time as
an entrepreneur which is
what you are if you are starting on
youtube if you're growing on youtube if
you want to go full time on youtube
you are an entrepreneur and so an
entrepreneur needs to know the numbers
you need to know what it's going to take
for you to go full time or
what it's going to take for your family
to be able to see this as a reality
maybe it's just you and you're single or
maybe you do have a family i think
this is something so important when it
comes to being a
smart entrepreneur and i know that's who
you are
i know that you're an entrepreneur that
takes risks but makes
calculated risks i know that you're an
entrepreneur who
wants to step out and make a difference
in the world but in order to do that
you've got to know the numbers
so do you know how much it would be for
you to go full time
do you know how much sacrifice or things
you would need to let go of
in order to make this a reality i can
tell you i've lived through the
sacrifice season
my husband and i lived in tens of
thousands of dollars in credit card debt
because i didn't know the numbers but
then once we were able
to figure out the numbers we got on the
same page we aligned
ourselves with what we wanted in our
lives everything changed
so if that's something you haven't
committed to yet i want to encourage you
to figure out what is your number what's
it going to take for you to go full
time and see this as a reality
and then lastly uh we went through all
seven steps
so now you have all seven steps for this
process
and this entire series was brought to
you by our free
youtube class at thinkmasterclass.com
if you've not been able to take that
class i recommend putting it on your
calendar
go over to thinkmasterclass.com register
for that free youtube class
and we're gonna help you we're gonna go
deeper into the three secrets for
success
on youtube you've learned these seven
steps but now let's go deeper
into actually making the plan right for
you if you have started a youtube
channel and you
feel lost or you want to figure out how
to connect the dots and
how what's it going to take to really go
all in we're going to help you with that
on
this class so make sure you register at
thinkmasterclass.com and if you got
value out of this podcast i recommend
that you hit subscribe
wherever you're consuming this content
and
if you're listening to this on itunes
did you know you can
rate and review the podcast what does
that mean it means you can
let us know what you think about this
podcast and today
i'm going to bring to you carrie's
review she said dynamic duo
this is a must listen for any business
owner who wants to create an
impact and stay relevant to the modern
consumer
bravo and well done hey carrie thank you
so much
for that podcast review it means so much
to me to be able to
hear your stories and hear what you
think about this podcast so
if you've got a little bit of extra time
today after this podcast before you head
to your next task
make sure to rate and review the podcast
and let us know
what has been your favorite episode so
far well that concludes our three-part
series of how to quit your job and go
full time on youtube if you haven't
listened to part one and part two i
highly recommend that you go back and
listen to those two episodes and
stay tuned for next week because we're
going to be taking a deep dive into what
i like to call
the clarity equation we're starting a
new two-part series brought to you by
thinkmasterclass.com and we're going to
be breaking down
what does it actually mean to get clear
on
youtube i can't wait to share this
two-part series
upcoming with you in the next episodes
thank you so much for being a part of
this community
for listening to this podcast for taking
us along
on your journey it means so much to me
as we are creating this content
that you are getting value and so i want
to applaud you for taking the time
out of your day to listen to this
podcast to be a part of this community
and for taking action on youtube
thanks so much and we'll catch it in the
next episode
you